aquí tenemos la función fx igual a la
integral de x ax al cuadrado de coseno
de t entre t
dt y queremos derivar la cómo le podemos
hacer pues parece ser que va a tener que
ver con el teorema fundamental del
cálculo pero hay que ser un poco
cuidadosos porque en el teorema
fundamental tenemos un resultado para
integrales definidas donde el límite
superior está en función de x pero aquí
ambos límites tanto el de arriba como el
de abajo están en función de x o sea
antes ya ya platicamos cómo hacerle para
lidiar con este x cuadrada si aquí
tuviéramos una constante aplicamos la
regla de la cadena y todos nos salía muy
bien pero ahora necesitamos un truco
adicional para para poder pasar esta
expresión a algo que ya sepamos
responder como ya hacemos para cambiar
esto pues vamos a ganar un poquito de
intuición primero y vamos a graficar
entonces de este lado déjame poner el
eje i
estoy acá va a ser el eje el eje y de
este otro lado voy a poner el eje t
el eje y a esta función que estamos
integrando la de aquí adentro déjame
llamarle ft
efe dt de este modo ftcv de alguna forma
por acá no sé supongamos que se ve más o
menos algo de este estilo claro o sea
seguro no se ve así porque coseno hace
otras cosas pero ahorita es muy muy en
general vale nada más para agarrar la
intuición entonces de esta de acá
efe dt y igual a efe dt y lo que
queremos aquí es determinar el área
entre xy x al cuadrado
otra vez como las cosas están más o
menos generales pues x puede quedar
antes de x al cuadrado o después pero
ahorita nada más para fijar ideas vamos
a pensar que x queda antes de x al
cuadrado entonces por acá queda x déjame
marcar como sube más o menos algo así
quizás debería escribir un poco más
grande x verdad a esta x y por acá en
algún otro lado tenemos x al cuadrado lo
voy a quitar con este color azul x al
cuadrado muy bien entonces tenemos más o
menos algo de este estilo
entonces esta integral lo que nos pide
hacer
encontrar el área debajo de la curva
fcc / x y x al cuadrado o sea esta área
que voy a marcar en color blanco esta
área de acá vale
esta de acá entonces el truco que vamos
a hacer el truco para encontrar esta
área es tomarnos un valor intermedio de
ese algo más o menos por este por este
lugar y vamos a expresar esta área que
queremos en términos de dos áreas va en
términos del área de la izquierda que
voy a pintar en color verde claro el
área de la izquierda y el área de la
derecha que corresponde a este color
azul y está a esta área de acá entonces
ese de ahí va a ser el truco y vas a ver
que va a salir muy bonito nada más que
tenemos que escribirlo con calma verdad
entonces vamos a pasarnos para acá para
escribir cómo sería esto entonces nos
quedaría igual a igual a y como
expresamos esto de acá pues lo partimos
en la integral de x ac va entonces
primero nos queda la integral la
integral de x ac de coseno dt voy a
ponerle se dejó seno de coseno dt
dividido entre t de t
y a eso tenemos que sumarle tenemos que
sumarle la de la derecha que va de c a
equis al cuadrado
entonces nos queda la integral la
integral
me quedan medio feos y símbolos de
integral a veces desea x al cuadrado de
jose no de t / / t de t muy bien
entonces ya tenemos nuestra función fx
partida en estos dos cachos ahora sí
vamos a derivar la déjame ponerle por
acá efe prima de x voy a reescribir la
la s mayúscula pero ahora derivada f
prima de x es igual a y ahora sí ahora
sí vamos a derivar utilizando el teorema
fundamental y las cosas que ya
platicamos antes mira la de acá de la
derecha cuando la tengamos que derivar
pues es el teorema fundamental con la
regla de la cadena y la laca de la
izquierda también ya practicamos cómo
hacer la verdad tenemos que pasar esta x
para arriba y ésta se para abajo y ya
dijimos que para eso simplemente hay que
intercambiar el límite superior y el
inferior y multiplicar por un signo
menos
como nos quedarían nos quedaría a ver
aquí intercambiamos los límites nos
quedan menos y el teorema fundamental
nos da coseno de equis entre x entonces
sería menos coseno de x / / / x y luego
hay que sumar la derivada de este lado
la derivada de ese lado se hace con
teorema fundamental también pero ahora
aplicando la regla de la cadena entonces
es la derivada de lo de afuera que sería
coseno de x / x pero evaluada en en x al
cuadrado en ese entonces sería más más
coseno de x al cuadrado dividido entre x
al cuadrado entre quizá al cuadrado pero
luego multiplicado por la derivada de lo
de adentro que en este caso sería la
derivada de x al cuadrado con respecto a
x entonces es multiplicar por 2 x y
básicamente ya terminamos nada más
déjame déjame reescribir esto para que
sea más bonito ya lo voy a poner todo en
color amarillo entonces cómo se
simplificaría estoy aquí no le podemos
hacer gran cosa nos queda
x dividido entre x y luego aquí está x
se cancela con esta x cuadrada y abajo
nos queda x entonces sería más o seno de
x cuadrada coseno de x cuadrada el 2 lo
voy a poner por acá va y tengo que
dividir entre x dividimos entre x ella
bueno ya casi está nada más déjame
juntar las fracciones para que no se vea
tan feo que esté separado el denominador
entonces nos quedaría todo dividido
entre x yo voy a poner primero el
positivo para que se vea más bonito
entonces nos quedaría dos veces coseno
de x al cuadrado ya eso tenemos que
restarle coseno de x y con esto
terminamos